race and we were talking about Joe Biden
there Steve Barclay is here with us this
morning your boss is over in Washington
at the moment would you have taken the
first pitch well the PM is really keen
on Cricket so perhaps if it was uh
bowling game perhaps he might have been
more likely but uh I think it's a great
honor for him to be there but also some
really serious uh business to do
particularly on things like AI on
getting that investment that uh we're
hoping to skew into the UK which is
great for jobs so a really important
visit you hear this morning talk about a
new weight loss drug um tell me about it
well I think it's really exciting I want
to make sure that the NHS is innovating
at the front of the queue in terms of
the latest drugs that are available and
we know that obesity is a real Health
Challenge 9 in 10 type 2 diabetics
overweight the second biggest cause of
cancer is obesity after smoking so we
know that the health benefits of
tackling obesity are extremely large but
we also know that for many people
watching this it's a real struggle to to
lose the weight to to keep that weight
off so we want to look at using a range
of things so we've got a pilot for
example in Wolverhampton looking at how
we incentivize healthy behaviors we've
got programs in schools for example
around school sports and PE funding but
we're also looking at what the latest
drugs are and the announcement today is
about the the latest drugs that can take
potentially 15 of people's weight off it
needs to be part of a wider package of
support in terms of their diet and their
lifestyle but it's really exciting and
that's what we're looking to Pilot and
pilot through Primary Care rather than
just in hospitals which is where these
Services have tended to be in the past
how do you stop it getting into the
wrong hands well by having it through
GPS and Primary Care by being for those
that have a BMI of 35 and a health
condition alongside that because I think
there are concerns around some patients
who might access it where it's not
appropriate and that's why we want to
make sure we've got the right wraparound
services that it is targeted at those
with a high uh overweight uh BMI 35 as
well and have that sort of Health
wrapper around that and that's really
what we'll be piloting and that's why
we're doing it through Primary Care okay
which is fantastic news but um I see
that you also did
disclosed forgive me two MPS at the NHS
in England had missed its Target to
ensure that all patients who've been
waiting 18 months for an operation in
hospital would be treated by April
what's going on well we've got to buy
over 90 uh well we cut it by over 90 we
got it to under 11 000 by at the end of
March if you look at that compared to
for example Wales where it was around 70
000 patients waiting 18 months in labor
run Wales and we've got a population in
England 18 times the size of Wales so a
huge amount of progress was made uh
overnight well by a very very narrow
margin we got it down by over 90 and
that's thanks to a huge amount of work
being done up and down the country by
social surgical team so we've got the
the recovery plan the elective recovery
plan we're rolling out their diagnostic
Centers we've got over 160 that we're
opening we've got new surgical hubs that
were opening to boost our capacity we
know there's a backlog from the pandemic
we cleared almost all the 78-week
weights by the end of March there was as
I say just under 11 000 left which were
focused on but it shows the plan is
working we've cleared the two-year
weights in the summer got that below
2000 we cleared over 90 by the end of
margin now we're focusing on those over
52 weeks there's still a big number that
you're going to have to sort out before
the next election
7.2 million people are still on the
waiting list that's a big number well it
is and of course not all of those are
waiting for impatience about four fifths
so those are waiting for outpatient
appointments about a fifth of inpatients
but it is it's a consequence of the
pandemic all health systems are facing
real challenges in terms of those uh
backlogs that's why we invested over 8
billion in our ellipses recovery it's
why we're also investing over 5 billion
pounds in the new Diagnostics surgical
herbs boosting our capacity there but
we'll also want to get it down to by the
next election uh well the election
recovery plan is to clear these long
Waits so next Target will be the 65
weeks and then the 52 we want to get
that down as much as possible and part
of the reason we're accelerating the
diagnostic hubs the surgical herbs is to
boost the capacity so we can get more
people treated but the plan is working
we hit our milestone in the summer we
cleared more than 90 percent by the end
of March in our second milestone and
that's really what we're focused on so
what are you going to get the number
down to by the next uh well the electric
recovery sets out for 52 weeks currently
the target's uh 200 000 by next march
but we obviously want to go further on
what we're in discussions with I'll be
seeing NHS leaders later this morning I
had a meeting with the sergeant Mackey
and Professor Tim Riggs who lead our
electric recovery program uh just
yesterday and we're really focused on
what more we can do to get those numbers
down but the plan is working we're
making progress and we're investing in
more capacity when was the last time you
met representatives for junior doctors
and nurses a couple of weeks ago we've
had we had three weeks of talks with the
junior doctors I don't think well I
don't think an offer of a 35 for pay
rise is what your viewers would be
receiving themselves for these numbers
to come down we do and and that's why
we're keen to work with them we've had
talks over a series of weeks with them I
think we need to have a place there well
I don't think 35 as a pay rise is a
reasonable ask of this is still a long
way apart so there is a distance apart
the government made them an offer we
want to work constructively with them we
hugely value the contribution that
Junior doctors make and we recognize the
the real pressures that they've faced as
a consequence of the pandemic but also
the pressures that the wider NHS is
under okay
um as I said you're still a well you
said you're still a distance apart what
would you give them how much would you
give them I'm not going to negotiate
live on air K and I don't think you
would uh expect me to ask you fifthly
visa to us but the equally visible for
me to say that that's not something
we're going to do live on air we had
discussions with them we set out a
reasonable offer we stand ready to to
engage further with them it was the
junior doctors sadly who broke up the
talks who then decided to to have
further strike action we want to
continue a discussion but I don't think
a 35 pay rise is a reasonable amount
talk to me about the covert inquiry why
would the government take its own
inquiry to court in a case that it's
almost certainly going to lose uh well
the camera offices is leading on that
and wants to clarify the legal position
in terms of what messages are disclosed
obviously there are issues in terms of
people's privacy and and their wider
rights in terms of what message may be
sent but anything to do with the inquiry
I think there's a recognition we usually
value the inquiry as you say we have set
up we have set up the inquiry we
massively
well the camera office wants to just
clarify the legal position about what is
it expressed the chair to do that well
of course we trust it the government
office wants to just clarify the legal
position around their messages and what
is and is not uh in scope uh but the the
work of the inquiry is massively
important that's why uh We've set it up
and people are very much looking forward
to of course we interested we have a
fantastic Judiciary uh World leading
Judiciary uh it's perfectly taxpayers
money no I think the the common office
wants to just clarify uh the legal scope
in terms of what is it's an Innovative
area uh to test and and that's something
they're coming off wants to clarify okay
talk to me about this covid
disinformation unit that I've been
reading about in the paper this morning
can you confirm that there was a
disinformation unit during covert well I
think there was a unit looking at for
example some of the the messages at the
time you may recall I think you covered
on the program where people are saying
things like having would cure education
of covid so so he's looking at some of
the messages that were out there at the
time making sure we got the right Public
Health messages to the public uh I think
people are recognizing that often
through social media people can get
messages that are not helpful from a
health perspective and so I think that
was the concepts in which the unit in
the coming after 2017 though should we
be concerned that the government is
monitoring the activity of individuals
it's not North Korea no no I mean the
common office will clarify exactly the
the scope of it but my understanding was
its focus was on those messages which
were seen to be sort of conflicting uh
with public health and ensuring that the
right messages could be going out to the
public and that was really the the much
more positive uh approach that it was
and what did you do if you didn't like
what people were saying well it's
perfectly reasonable that there will be
a range of views and and my
understanding of the unit's work is that
was not the territory it was focused on
it was focused on where messages could
have a particular
impact on patients and making sure we
can get the right messages out to people
and and that's uh that's my
understanding of its key Focus okay we
are out of time but it's always a
pleasure to talk to you house secretary
thank you very much